anyway welcome to another welcome to the
your energy right now dude
your energy right now is negative you
don't know why
well i will get to that now okay but i'm
having a bad day as well
so you know let's start with nothing
my day's been good i understood it's
just i knew i was coming to see you
right and so um i've had a really [ __ ]
up day
so i i wish that your energy and your
and your attitude was a little bit more
positive
well it's you came in real angry yeah
well it's hard to have a positive energy
when you're on the documentary talking
about my mom's vagina
yeah let's just get that out of the way
i've yeah you said something about like
used to massage my mom
and then you said something about her
vagina
yeah i never said anything about your
mouth i haven't seen the document i've
never seen the documentary
yeah well you should watch what you said
in it what
it's pretty bad dude okay what did i say
about your mom's vagina i love your mom
something about she's got a great video
her vagina in the air
in the back of the main room yeah but
that's that's no no no no
that was pretty [ __ ] gnarly no one
talks about you know what i mean
even the african-american canadians
don't talk about my mom's vagina
you're like talking about my mom mitzi
shore the legend
comedian comedy store you're like oh
everyone had sex with her
and her vagina's in the air here at the
comedy store and
used to massage her and have sex with
her i never
i never said that yeah i didn't say he
had said yeah yeah yeah you just just
did say that but
for the record for the record dude do
you ever been to russia are you
poisoning me like russia like that guy
recovered here or the rec i recovered
for the record okay
and for the record this isn't a
deposition i i know i know but for the
record i wanna
in your [ __ ] dumb garage well okay
it doesn't i didn't know it was a garage
those people watching yeah it's in a
[ __ ] garage
this is it like this ghetto around here
yeah it's a studio
no it's not it's a [ __ ] garage dude
there might be a [ __ ] car that comes
to the side
okay all right so all right now
i want to i don't remember saying that
it is something that i would say so
let's just get that that's a factual
thing
number two error that part yeah you
would think that they would cut it out
and i'm gonna have a discussion with my
binder
you would think that they would cut it
out and i would and and thirdly you said
something about [ __ ] her
[ __ ] or something no i never said that
okay well you haven't seen the
documentary
why would i say that i had sex with your
mom you
wasn't [ __ ] the other chinese
comedian guy
asian kimmy peter chen yeah it wasn't
him was he in the documentary yes
[Laughter]
he's the best yeah i know what the [ __ ]
happened to him i don't know
he had the best he had the best you know
what he was best
you know how when somebody would heckle
you have like
a retort a comic yeah his retorts never
made any sense
where were they one time when he like
some guy heckled him he go you shut up
or i'm gonna put you on a rocket ship
and fly you to the moon
[Laughter]
uh i wanna apologize for that and um i
will watch the documentary
and i feel really bad about it i can't
believe i said something like that about
your mom i love your mom
she saved my life she changed why are
you looking in the camera you have cross
side your eyes are crossed
i know so many main people don't know
can i tell you what happened to me today
so that maybe you could have be a little
nicer than me
okay but you apologize with the mom i
did i think the mom thing is like a
serial offense because he shot this
thing for jfl in um
in toronto and he did the same thing but
it was about my mom
wow and i flipped them yeah it's not
cool dude you can't i mean talk about
girls vaginas but not [ __ ] someone's
moms
it's like you know what i mean you
remember and then you talked about you
remember i apologize i
i'm gonna put we're rolling right yeah
we're rolling
mom's vaginas are awesome all right i'm
gonna apologize to anybody out there
if i made fun of your mother's vagina i
do it to santino a lot too
right yeah his mom his mom's vagina yeah
wow but he goes after her and she's too
yeah she goes after my mom too
and it's bullying it's not a good thing
yeah it's i don't know i'm laughing it's
terrible
it's terrible i apologize where are you
going i'm just taking this okay okay
so um i applaud i sincerely apologize
for making fun of your mom's vagina yeah
i've never seen it i was nice you were
in shock really
yeah oh i'm sorry man why would binder
keep that in i said a lot of things he
interviewed me a thousand times
and he would keep that in that's the
only thing he kept did yeah
that sucks anyway i apologize
i love you it's okay i'm sorry okay nice
to talk to you through [ __ ] plexiglas
it's like you have cancer
[Laughter]
do they know that does the audience know
there's a plexiglas yeah yeah they do
okay
they do i choose
yeah so um you moved to vegas